breaking news for American Education the
Republican front runner for president
wants to bring Trump University to all
Americans for free I'm announcing today
we will take the billions and billions
of dollars that we will collect by
taxing fining and suing excessively
large private university endowments and
we will then use that money to endow a
new institution called the American
Academy its Mission will be to make a
truly worldclass education available to
every American free of charge and do it
without adding a single dime to the
federal debt this institution will
gather an entire universe of the highest
quality educational content covering the
full spectrum of human Knowledge and
Skills and make that material available
to every American citizen online for
free the academy will award the full and
complete equivalent of a bachelor's
degree in addition to help the 4 million
Americans who have some college
education but no degree the American
Academy will grant credit for past
coursework at Legacy institutions and
give you the chance to complete your
education at the American Academy for
free and much more quickly than is now
possible or available the libs are going
to lose their minds as will the
Libertarians as will the Republican
establishment as will many fancy
conservative movements types who went to
brand name schools and fill their
mahogany home libraries with many Dusty
books and yet this is a great idea I
love this idea not because I am
convinced that the American Academy will
provide the best kind of education
around but rather because the education
system that we've got today basically
can't get any worse since the 1960s the
organized radical left has taken over
virtually every educational institution
in America especially the college
colleges and universities including the
fancy prestigious name brand schools
that is the left's epicenter of power
what Trump is suggesting here is a pure
political power play bleed the left's
power center of its funding and of the
malleable Minds that it
shapes you say online schools are an
ideal sure but virtually every lib
school in America already offers online
courses and online courses make it much
easier for students to transfer out of
those lib schools including if they've
got a lot of credits but they haven't
yet graduated including if they've taken
some cour work but don't have a degree
you can just transfer all that over from
the lib school to Trump's conservative
School free college is a bad idea you
say because it dilutes the quality of
the degree and makes the system beholden
to government apparates sure I totally
agree but that's already the case at
most liberal schools and Democrats inch
nearer and nearer every single election
cycle to flooding their own schools all
the lib schools with the same type of
funding that Trump is talking about only
orders of magnitude
higher Trump's Academy you say might not
properly teach Aristotle and
Shakespeare sure but neither do Harvard
and Yale at this point to say nothing of
the less prestigious much more highly
attended schools that teach little more
these days than racial resentment sexual
confusion and contempt for our
country conservatives like to talk a
good game about mixing up our strategy
and recapturing the institutions and
bleeding the organized left of its
political
power if we're serious about doing that
this is a great way to do it if we're
not if we've just been bluffing this
whole time then we can keep up the same
old Playbook that has for more than half
a century consistently handed the libs
virtually every institution in America
and then we can pride ourselves on our
devotion to the dubious principle of
always losing on Michael nlls this is
the Michael nolles
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show Elon Musk one
of the big Tech Giants seems to
suggest that the 2020 election might
have been a little bit
sketchy he seems to be on board now with
the
so-called election deniers we'll get to
that in a second first I don't want to
move off the Trump University thing or
sorry the American Academy under Donald
Trump too quickly because there's going
to be one objection here and the
objection is well beyond the spending
beyond the new government power beyond
the quality of the
education if conservatives get on board
with this idea in principle when a
republican is in office then when a
Democrat is in office they're going to
use the American Academy to achieve
their own ends they're going to they're
going to make the American Academy super
liberal and it's going to have the
backing of the government and all this
funding and you can transfer in and blah
blah blah two responses to that
objection
one the left already has that power
because they control statistically all
of the universities in the
country and those universities receive a
ton of government funding and they're
moving more and more toward free college
and and debt forgiveness for student
debt and all the rest of it they already
have that so there's there there's very
little for conservatives to lose by
attempting to carve out our own little
Center of power in that same universe
but second of all
Trump could or at least conservatives
could in theory establish the American
Academy such that it would be very
difficult to replace the teachers and
the administrators with huge Libs and
the reason I know that that is the case
is because that's exactly what the libs
have done at all the other schools since
the 1960s what the libs have done is
they've gotten themselves into the
universities the radicals from the 60s
are now to borrow a phrase from Roger
Kimble the tenured radicals of the 9s
and 20 all the way up to present day and
by reforming quote unquote I think
deforming but they say reforming the way
that the schools conduct University
business giving the faculty a greater
say in hiring and giving the Deans and
the deputy Deans and the deputy
assistant Deputy deans of diversity
equity and inclusion a greater say in
Personnel they essentially lock
themselves in so you've got a critical
mass of Libs on the faculty and in the
administration
and then they change the hiring process
and all the rules such that they
basically only hire themselves so now
it's virtually impossible to crack
through the the one example I've seen of
of a conservative going in there and
cracking up that lock would be Governor
Dan santis at new college in Florida who
went in and he said I'm going to make an
example out of this school and I'm going
to run rough shot over the libs who are
locking out the conservatives and he
installed a a good solid new board and
is Rec crafting the curriculum to be
solid and conducive to Virtue and
flourishing and knowledge but that's one
example otherwise the left has done a
great job at locking in their power
there conservatives could do the same if
we would simply mimic the tactics albeit
when we do it in a just way toward good
ends not as the libs often
do sometimes in an unjust way and always
toward very very evil ends not good
stuff we got to we've you've got to
amass some power and when you want to
amass some power in politics often you
got to amass some wealth when you want
to amass wealth one thing you ought to
check out is Birch gold right now text
nolles to 98 9898 yet again we're facing
the threat of a government shutdown and
of course the administration will deal
with it the same way they always do with
more spending which will inevitably
devalue the dollar protect your savings
by diversifying into gold with the help
of Birch gold group when you open an IRA
with Birch gold for every $10,000 you
spend by December 22nd Birch gold will
send you a free gold bar just text
nolles kwes to 98 9898 to claim
eligibility before Black Friday Birch
gold can even help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
without taking any money out of pocket
and you still get the free gold bars
with an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied customers you can count on
Birch gold to help you transition an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
do not let your savings fall victim to
the further devaluation of the dollar
text nolles to 98 9898 receive a free
info kit on gold and claim your
eligibility before Black Friday to
receive free gold bars on your
qualifying purchase that is nolles kwes
to
9898 98 speaking of unfortunate products
of American higher education Barack
Obama has gone viral over the weekend
for chiming in on the outbreak of war in
the Middle East some some conservatives
have pointed out that Obama era policies
driven directly by Barack Obama Vis
Israel and the Palestinian territories
in the broader Middle East would appear
to be directly responsible for what's
going on Obama says hey hey hey no man
come on it's all of our fault the
problem with the social media and trying
to tick
tock activism and trying to debate this
on that
is you can't speak the truth you can
pretend to speak the truth you can speak
one side of the
truth and in some cases you can try to
maintain your moral innocence but that
won't solve the problem and so if you
want to solve the problem then you have
to take in the whole
truth and you then have to
admit nobody hands are
clean
that all of us are complicit to some
degree okay there we go for the first
part of that I thought Obama was
channeling his inner kamla Harris and
Obama's a pretty smart guy so and when
you want to discuss the truth you need
all the and the whole truth and we
nothing but the truth and so we when we
we on our debates we don't we're a
little narrow and shallow and we don't
always and I said what are you babbling
about get to the point says listen this
war in the Middle East it's all our
fault oh uh no it isn't no it isn't at
all actually because here's the thing
here's the thing during the Obama
Administration he and his team made a
conscious decision to weaken the state
of Israel and to embolden the enemies of
the state of Israel and they had all
sorts of arguments and reasons for doing
so and in fact we're seeing some of
those arguments now in real time on
Twitter and in the
streets and with the people waving the
Palestine flag making a Ruckus in cities
around the country and around the world
saying from The River To The Sea
Palestine will be free saying that they
want to abolish the state of Israel
Obama never explicitly went that far but
he he clearly undermined the state of
Israel in fact he sent one of his top
campaign advisers to go OU BB Netanyahu
in Israel then he then he
obsequiously bowed down at every turn to
the leaders of Iran and gave them a
bunch of money and didn't punish them
for capturing our Sailors and it was a
complete
joke no surprise you saw some aggression
during his administration then Trump
comes in and it's all good and you see
the Abraham Accords being signed and you
see relative peace in the Middle East
who would have imagined Donald Trump the
reality TV show host the Real Estate
Mogul would bring peace to the Middle
East he did it and then Biden comes in
as Obama's third term and what happens
you see the biggest outbreak of war in
the Middle East in many
decades well we all bear some
responsibility I agree with Barack Obama
that politics and territorial disputes
and Holy Wars wars of religion are
complicated I agree with
that but when it comes to this
war this is directly attributable to the
Obama
policies and it's it's it's just like
any kid whoever ever gets caught doing
anything bad he just instantly well you
know listen you know it's really
complicated actually I think it's sort
of all isn't it kind of all of our fault
when you really think about it no man
it's you you got you're you did it I got
your hand in the cookie jar well no but
when you really think about it we all
stole the cookies didn't we no when you
really think about it not so and you see
the administration doing this today
Obama's thirdd term in the form of Joe
Biden is now sending out its spokesman
National Security Council spokesman John
Kirby to say definitively that Joe Biden
would
veto a funding bill for the state of
Israel if they lose the the Ukraine
funding the president would veto an only
Israel Bill we I think that we've made
that clear there you go the one silver
lining in I think a pretty dangerous
policy
here is that this would seem to undercut
the argument that the Jews control
everything
you know there's been this idea for a
long time that the Jews control
everything because the Jews have done
very well in lots of industries that are
very important all over the world so you
could you could sort of see why people
might come to that
conclusion but if the Jews control
everything what why can't they get
funding from the United
States for this war why why if the Jews
control everything why is it that the
Biden Administration is willing to
gamble with the security of the state of
Israel potentially with the right of the
state of Israel to exist Netanyahu is
saying this is a second war for
independence strictly so that they can
pressure Republicans to support Ukraine
war funding which is immensely unpopular
among a a broad swath of Americans
including Independents and
Democrats wouldn't you think if the Jews
controlled everything wouldn't you think
they'd already just have passed that
Israel only Bill and then they'd move on
to Ukraine or whatever but no that's not
what's going on here Joe Biden like
Barack
Obama does does not have a particularly
strong defense of the state of Israel
and so he's willing to gamble a little
bit and say all right Republicans you
want to cut out Taiwan funding you want
to cut out Ukraine funding especially
all right well then we're going to hold
up the Israel funding bill because they
know that Republicans are much more pro
Israel than the Democrats are and for
for Democrats right now Israel is a
really losing issue because while the
donors largely still support the state
of Israel the on the ground Rank and
file members of the Democrat party are
pro- Palestine Liberation they're the
ones in the streets marching with the
Palestine Flags they're the ones
marching with BLM BLM which posts a a
picture on social media of a paraglider
celebrating the Hamas terror attack on
that on that concert
Festival so politically it's much wiser
for Joe Biden to say yeah we're going to
hold up the bill and that way at least
we'll maybe get some Ukraine funding and
that'll at least be somewhat popular
among
Democrats very dangerous game here
though
because as I've said from the
beginning the American interest here is
to contain the
war
the emboldening of Islamic Terror groups
like Hamas and
Hezbollah uh and Iran for that
matter that will not help to contain the
war that will only help the war to
spread if there is actually an
existential threat to the state of
Israel and Israel say starts threatening
to use nuclear weapons or something like
that that is not a way to contain the
war contain the war does not just mean
hey ceasefire everybody stop contain the
war
means permit Israel to defend itself to
achieve what it needs to achieve namely
the ousting of Hamas which is an
unacceptable security threat for the
state of
Israel and
then contain any potential expansion of
the war which is already expanded
continuously but to just say hey we're
not we're going to hold up all funding
and make this situ situation even more
tense and less certain is a recipe for
World War III which is something that
Joe Biden and his ideological
predecessor Barack Obama have excelled
at that was the old joke after Obama got
elected Obama the worst foreign policy
president in my entire lifetime who who
came out and
said I remember the argument they said
if you vote for John McCain you're going
to get another war in the Middle East
this was the argument in 2008 and then
what happened I voted for John McCain
and we got more wars in the Middle East
and North Africa and
elsewhere now speaking of funding the
war in the Middle East here here's one
that's really going to make the libs
head spin and it it shows you the
complexity of war that armchair
quarterbacks armchair generals generally
do not appreciate Wall Street Journal
has a report at now that the
russia-backed
paramilitary group The Wagner group you
remember the Wagner group formerly led
by this guy named Pria who turned on
Vladimir Putin and started marching his
paramilitary toward Moscow lost his
gumption at the last minute turned back
around and then he had an unfortunate
plane crash that I'm sure Vladimir Putin
had nothing to do with but the Wagner
group the vagna group if you if you want
to sound really scary about it uh a very
serious military force does a lot of
fighting for Russia so the russia-backed
Wagner group is reportedly looking to
send Advanced Air Defense systems to the
Middle East my question is what is the
average purple-haired American liberal
supposed to think about this
because the Palestine Liberation people
are good depending on how radically left
you are if you're in antifa or BLM you
will explicitly support Hamas and
Hezbollah so those guys are good because
they're attacking the state of Israel
but those guys are now getting support
from Russia which is is very bad because
Ukraine is good and Russia is bad
because Russia they're the new Nazis
even though they're fighting Ukraine
which has incorporated elements of
Neo-Nazi movement into its military but
that country is led by a Jew and the
Jews are now the
Nazis even though the Jews are the most
prominent victims of the real Nazis who
existed 78 years
ago
so we're pro wag is are the libs Pro
Wagner now or
they're because they're Pro Hamas I
don't know you know what it tells
me tells me war is very very complicated
and everyone who is trying to simplify
the war down into a 5-second sound bite
or a few bullet points on the back of a
napkin they are risking expanding the
war which is already extraordinarily
complex and then you know who's really
risking
danger to America in this war the top
brass at the Pentagon who are holding up
our military Readiness because they want
to push radical social policies doesn't
look good when you want to look good
though you got to check out jell right
now go to jus.com if you can believe it
Thanksgiving is just two weeks away just
in time for the holidays Jus cell is
offering their best sale of the year
right now you can get 70 70% off Jus
cell's most popular package which now
includes Jus cell 3 their newest under
eye treatment gen cell 3 will have you
looking years younger it uses advanced
technology to deliver complex vitamins
and minerals directly to your face for
instant hydration say goodbye to Fine
Lines crows feet under eye bags and dark
spots Jus cell will have you looking and
feeling your absolute best guaranteed or
your money back no questions asked our
talent manager Tessa absolutely loves
using the genucel under eye cream you
deserve to look and feel your best this
holiday season I also just love the
founder of this company a to Christian
from Egypt who left Egypt for the
American dream go to Jus cell.com
kwes to get this incredible holiday
discount for 77% off their most popular
package which includes the jusl 3 and
Dark Spot Corrector get results in 12
hours or less immediate effects are free
Jus cell.com
70% off plus free priority shipping Jus
cell.com
slns the daily wire has just launched
Ben key our brand new kids entertainment
platform we are all obviously sick of
Hollywood pushing their leftist
propaganda on our kids and now there's
finally an answer for those of us
looking for Children's shows that we can
trust bent key is available to download
right now and is dedicated to creating
the next generation of Timeless stories
that transport kids into a world of
Adventure imagination and joy I could
have never imagined that DW was going to
provide all of this to our members
without increasing the price of an
annual membership in fact I strongly
believe that we ought to have charged
everybody a lot more money because this
is expensive content and it's it's
unbelievably well done and even in my
wildest dreams I know it was going to be
good stuff I didn't realize how much
would be included with the new daily
wire kids offering bent key this is the
greatest value ad that we have ever
given it's a $99 value that you get
completely for free which goes to show
that we don't just talk about changing
the culture we put it into action if
you're already a daily W plusus member
we already have bent key just download
the app to start streaming now if you
are not a member there's never been more
value to joining than right now you get
all of the daily wire plusus content
that you know and love plus bent key at
no additional cost and speaking of the
military Ronda
santis had something great come out over
the weekend which is he answered the
call to defend Tommy tuberville Tommy
tuberville the Republican senator who is
holding up Joe Biden's military
promotions because the Pentagon decided
to push a radical IAL pro-abortion
policy the Pentagon decided that they
were going to take taxpayer dollars and
pay service members to go to different
states to fly to different states to
kill their children through abortion
because the dobs decision from the
Supreme Court limited the Constitutional
license to abortion so after dobs comes
out after roie Wade is
overruled the Pentagon top Rass they say
hey it's really really important to be a
fighting force it is really really
important that we pay our service
members to kill their own children no
matter how difficult it is even if they
have to fly across the country we are
going to pay our service members to kill
their own children which seems contrary
to the purpose of the military the
purpose of the US military is to protect
us and kill our
enemies the purpose of the US military
is not to kill our own children that
would be to my mind the very opposite of
the purpose of the US military so Tommy
tuberville heroically stands up and says
you're not getting your promotions
you're not getting more top brass out
there at the Pentagon until you roll
back this policy we are still a
government of the People by the people
for the people I am an elected
representative of the people we're not
going to let you wacko far- leftists who
have infiltrated the US military the
last conservative institution in America
we're not going to allow you to spend
our money without any oversight to this
evil evil end and a bunch of the
squishes have turned against Tommy
tuberville but Ronda santis just came
out and defended him do you agree that
Tommy tuberville should lift the
blockade on Military promotions do you
agree with Republicans and the Senate
actually I think that what the dod is
doing I don't think they're following
the law with respect to the abortion
tourism I don't think taxpayer money
should be spent on that uh we have a
very weak defense industrial base we've
got huge problems with recruiting and so
their focus on that I don't think it's
consistent with the law I also think
it's misguided I would also point out
that you can promote people um on an
individual basis I think the Senate has
decided they have not wanted to move a
lot of those but if there's people that
are mission critical they can move it um
in spite of what Senator tubble did but
I think fighting back on the Pentagon
going outside the boundaries of the law
I think that's congress's appropriate
role for oversight and checks and
balances But to answer the question do
you think that Senator tuberville should
lift the blockade that he's put on
Military
promotions no because I think that he
we're trying to force a change in
Pentagon policy to conform them to the
law while at the same time he has
allowed individuals to be to be
appointed uh so if there are mission
critical promotions bring them before
the Senate I think he's been very clear
that that's appropriate and I know that
they have done that um in certain
instances totally right on finally
finally you're hearing a republican in
elected office in this case someone
who's running for president say the
obvious Tommy tuberville is a hero this
is an excellent excellent move by him
very courageous and the squishes who are
standing on the sidelines keeping their
mouth shut while the top Rass at the
Pentagon transforms our military into an
American baby killing machine can you
imagine and and the the even worse the
squishes on the Republican side who are
attacking Tommy tuberville those those
people deserve
contempt in public
life DeSantis totally right here and I
want to hear more Republicans saying it
why is it taking the governor of Florida
the number two guy the presidential race
to to be among the first prominent
Republicans to defend tuberville I want
to hear every elected Republican defend
Tommy tuberville now that was good stuff
I'm very very happy with DeSantis for
this unfortunately uh Governor desus
followed that answer with a very bad
answer also on MSNBC and the answer was
what should happen to president Trump if
he is convicted in any of these show
trials brought by the liberal
regime do you really believe that a man
who's convicted of say attempting to
overturn the 2020 election or taking
nuclear secrets back to his Beach Club
do you actually still as we sit here
today believe that person should be
president so I signed a pledge uh Willie
and uh that that pledge is what it is
now do I think somebody under those
circumstances could get elected
president the answer is no um that will
not happen I think that Republican
voters will understand that as as we get
closer to to to voting uh but it is it
would be fatal in a general election and
I don't think the party should should
nominate um in that
situation
okay I guess DeSantis needs to give this
answer I guess because Dan santis is
running against Trump so he wants Trump
out of the primary Dan santis is running
against Trump he needs to convince
voters that Trump is not electable under
any
circumstances and it's easy to say
especially when teed up by MSNBC host
that if Trump is convicted by the very
very legitimate courts and trials that
are bringing him up on very serious
charges not a complete Banana Republic
show trial stalinesque nonsense no no
this is all very serious Donald Trump
one time it looks like he may have
jaywalked in New York City can you
imagine send him to the gulags for 150
years I guess gandis needs to give that
answer because he's running against
Trump but it's a very bad answer
because it accepts the premise the
liberal premise that these trials are
somehow legitimate they're
not they're not part of the evidence
that the trials are not legitimate other
than the content of these trials other
than how unprecedented it is that a
former president and current leader of
an opposition party of the ma of the
opposition party would be indicted the
federal level at the state level over
over supposed crimes that have never
been prosecuted against a president that
that the former opponent of Donald Trump
with far less right certainly committed
more clearly than Donald Trump ever did
in the case of Hillary Clinton's
classified email
Scandal it accepts the premise that this
is all somehow legitimate instead of the
show trial that it is and that's no good
because not only do Republican voters
know that this is a political
persecution almost entirely divorced
from the law many Democrats know that
too polls of whether or not Donald Trump
is being politically persecuted through
these trials show a clear majority of
Americans that means including
Independents and
Democrats believe that it's a political
persecution so then you've got you've
got DeSantis I guess necessarily from
his
standpoint echoing left-wing talking
points pretty crucial leftwing talking
points even justifying implicitly the
show trial of Donald Trump and the
principle that a former president and
current leader of of the opposition
party so long as he's a republican could
be prosecuted for this nonsense very
very bad and it once again speaks to The
Impossible position Dan santis is in
which is that desantis's whole candidacy
is premised on being Donald Trump 2.0
bigger better faster stronger more
articulate more focused more this you
like the original you're going to love
the new version that's the that's the
whole
pitch e even the way that the desandis
campaign is speaking out they're saying
Donald Trump he's not the man he was in
2016 that's the new talking point from
the disantis campaign and I I guess it's
the best one they've got but that only
doubles down on the notion that DeSantis
is Trump 2.0 yeah we love Trump 2016 but
I'm going to be the real Trump 2016 the
current Donald Trump of 2023 2024 he's
just he's lost a step he's not what he
promised us he would be I'm the
Fulfillment of the Trump promise okay
well if that's the case you're going to
turn off the moderates and the squishes
and the establishment people in the in
the
GOP
but you you're probably not going to
pull enough Trump people over so then
you've got to you got to go on over and
sort of side with the squishes and the
moderates and the establishment people
and you got to go on MSNBC and you got
to make that case and that's going to
involve echoing some of the lib talking
points that are totally going to turn
off the Trump people so you're left even
though you're seemingly the the
strongest candidate in the race because
you've got all the Trump bonafides but
you're you're also more polished and
clubbable so you appeal a little bit
more to the people who just simply don't
like Trump's temperament and personality
you go from looking like the strongest
guy in the race into a man without a
home into a man without a country which
is I think being reflected in the polls
and it's unfortunate because the guy's
pretty solid but he's just in I think an
impossible
situation now speaking of election
security and fraud Elon Musk just
tweeted out he didn't tweet it I guess
he Zed it out he ex he exed it out a
video of a woman stuffing a
2020 outdoor mailin ballot drop off box
so you can see here looking at here as
we pull this up same basic
thing it looks like the same Dropbox
everybody look at all those people doing
the right
thing right cut the line so this is a
maroon dress woman or is this somebody
else yeah yeah I know that's is that
your mule that's our look at that this
is a mule in front of everyone okay
sitting there watching like what so this
is happening right now as she opens it
up oh can't figure out to open up you
hear hear Charlie Charlie voice at what
point after the first now it's a felony
so this is a felon three felons at One
Drop Box
everybody want you to think about that
one after the other and broad daylight I
mean now you could also get driver's you
know license plate info and stuff right
yes so she in broad daylight while
everyone else was watching just violated
Georgia law right yeah and so Elon
tweets this out and just says
H
H which is good
news I have from the beginning felt that
the 2020 election was a little bit dodgy
the moment I saw those numbers turn
coincident with the uh pipes bursting in
Georgia and the the election overseers
being curiously shut out of some of the
precincts and the whole process of
counting being shut down for a few hours
in the middle of the night then going on
for days and weeks I thought you know
this election doesn't seem totally on
the up and up really from the moment
that the libs changed the voting rules
in some cases to violate the law and
state constitutions like in the case of
Pennsylvania and to enable widespread
mail on ballots and the ballot drop off
boxes I thought you know this isn't good
this is Rife and open for fraud as
Barack Obama said 10 years ago Barack
Obama before this scheme became
fashionable for Democrats and they
thought they could really win it Obama
himself and his team came out and said
oh no unsecured widespread mail and
ballots that's really dangerous that
opens up the possibility of voter fraud
then they realized they were very good
at it so so so they've encouraged it but
this is big news not the not the fact
that these people seem to be cheating
but the fact that Elon Musk is promoting
it because don't forget the way if the
2020 election were rigged to the point
that that it were stolen that you got
that that had it not been so rigged
Donald Trump would have won some people
are saying well it was rigged but Biden
would have won anyway okay if it were if
it were rigged to the point that it
changed the outcome of the elction
election then
the chief villains in that story really
are not the little election workers or
the people on the ground harvesting the
ballots and signing them themselves and
stuffing it into the drop boxes the big
villains were the oligarchs in big Tech
because it was big Tech that censored
damaging information about Joe Biden
that alone could have thrown the
election to Biden censoring the Hun
Biden laptop
story and it was big Tech that funded
this whole rigging don't forget it was
Mark Zuckerberg and big Tech who funded
the the schemes and the
organizations that were responsible for
the widespread mail and ballots and the
dropboxes in one case putting the
dropboxes illegally far away from the
county clerk's
offices so big Tech was complicit and
then the moment you raised any questions
about the election big Tech shut you
down canceled your account demonetized
your show did all all sorts of things
what I don't just mean to single ad
Zuckerberg it was all of them and
now finally we have a conservative
running one of the big Tech platforms
the smallest one but still a prominent
one punches above its weight because a
lot of a lot of Jos and people with a
big reach are on that platform formerly
known as Twitter now known as X so now
implausibly totally unexpectedly you've
got the the chief group responsible for
rigging the election as far as I'm
concerned big Tech has now been
infiltrated by someone who is
more amenable to conservative views and
desires and who is questioning the
election who is violating their Chief
Prohibition in the days after the 2020
election that's pretty good stuff we
need to make our elections
bulletproof and we need to make you
bulletproof too which is why you got to
check out bulletproof everyone right now
go to bulletproof everyone.com promo
code Nolls kwes bulletproof everyone is
a premier American body armor
manufacturer and supplier designed and
built for everyday wear their unique
armor systems offer 25% more coverage
than standard armor while maintaining
flexibility and all day wearability
bulletproof everyone's ultra light armor
system is so light and thin you might
forget you're wearing it your safety and
discretion are their top concern unless
someone puts their hands on you no one
will have any clue that you're protected
with bulletproof everyone you are not a
walking billboard there are no visible
logos and no flashy designs they are
comfortable tailor made clothing system
that goes above and beyond adding
additional security by keeping you
Incognito and under the radar work or
play bullet prove everyone who's got the
perfect armor system to fit your
everyday lifestyle and everyday budget
right now our listeners can get 10% off
plus a free bulletproof backpack with
the purchase of any bulletproof clothing
just use code nlls at checkout at
bulletproof every.com that's bulletproof
everyone.com promo code nolles my
favorite comment last week is from
Shelly eisenhart 629 who says
Michael I normally fast forward through
the intros of a lot of YouTube shows I
follow I love watching yours and your
dance on a serious note thank you for
all of your great information thank you
you know we went back and forth on it
because the intro is a
little gay I I think we would all have
to it's a little it's literally light in
the loafers in that my loafers are kind
of light and they're dancing on the desk
and look it's I know it's sometimes hard
to tell the difference between an
Italian and one who is light a European
and one who is liting the for his I
being American but of Italian extraction
it's confusing okay but but the thing
that pushed me over the edge on why I
think it's kind of a funny intro is on
the one hand the libs are accusing me of
being a genocidal Maniac who wants to
slaughter all of the people in the world
or something because I pointed out at
CPAC
that and then on the other hand they're
going to call me a finocchio and say
that I'm liting the loafers because I
dance on my desk and I think that's kind
of fun I like that I like just kind of
putting a little wrench in the gears of
the liberal mind so as far as I'm
concerned the intro stays and I'm glad
that you like it as
well speaking of voter fraud there's a
lot of evidence of it there's a lot of
evidence of voter fraud guys and
consequential voter fraud there's a
judge in Connecticut Superior Court
Judge William Clark who has just ordered
the results of a recent mayoral primary
election in Bridgeport Connecticut
State's largest city to be overturned
and for a new election to be held so not
just well we found some issues but no no
no this election is null and void we
were going to hold a new election that's
how bad the rigging
was sometimes you hear with with the
2020 presidential election that well
Trump's lawyers tried to make their case
in court and they
failed that mostly isn't true mostly
what happened is the Trump lawyers tried
to make their case in court and the
courts didn't want to hear it because
the courts don't want to get involved
because they don't want to be blamed for
picking
one person or the other so they mostly
said nah no thanks we're not we're not
interested see you later which is what
courts often do that's what that's what
the Supreme Court did in the 1948 senate
election in Texas in which LBJ a future
president stole the seat almost
certainly stole the seat and the Supreme
Court said no we don't want anything to
do with it so we're talking about a
mayoral election here in Bridgeport
Connecticut where the stakes are
relatively low consider the stakes for
presidential election no one's going to
want to that with a 10-ft pole but here
in this mayoral election the judge came
down and said that bridgeport's
incumbent mayor Joe ganam won the
election as a result of significant
fraud and what kind of fraud you guessed
it fraud involving absentee ballots the
volume of evidence in this case he
writes including many hundreds of hours
of video surveillance disclosed and
accepted into evidence is perhaps
unprecedented in the state of
Connecticut in an election
case you've got video after video after
video as some are seeing in the 2020
presidential election this this probably
only happened in Bridgeport Connecticut
right this this was probably
inconsequential right it could look
there's always fraud this is what you
hear from the people who
excuse what very possibly occurred in
2020 well look there's always fraud but
you know it doesn't necessarily swing an
election yeah but sometimes it does and
to swing a presidential election you
don't need to swing 300 million votes
you just need to swing a handful of
counties which will swing a handful of
districts which will swing the whole
election then you look and you see
you've got certain bellweather counties
that generally determine which way the
election goes and you say hold on in the
2020 election 17 or 18 bellweather
counties out of what 19 went for Donald
Trump only one or two went for Joe Biden
does that make a lot of I don't
know but many because the the fact or
the the potential fact because the
hypothesis is so difficult to bear that
an election really could have been
rigged to the point of of getting the
wrong answer a lot of people will just
keep their heads down and say no no it
probably was okay it probably well now
now you're just sauntering into a
political buzs saww because yeah you're
not going to undo the 2020 election
where there's not going to be a point
where US Marshals lead Joe Biden out of
the Oval Office and they lead Donald
Trump in and they say sorry sir yes we
now know for certain it was a stolen
election and anyway you can undo all the
Biden stuff and hey there's not going to
be a war in the Middle East anymore and
there's not Russia is not going to
invade Ukraine anymore and we're going
to undo that's not of course and the
economy is going to be good again yeah
no that's not going to happen but if you
don't acknowledge the very plausible
scenario in which the 2020 election was
rigged in a consequential way then
you're you're not going to do a lot to
fix it before 2024 you're going to end
up in the same spot but the squishes are
still irate over the mere
suggestion that the 2020 election was
rigged here is Ken Buck a more liberal
Republican coming out and and saying
he's he's actually going to quit
Congress
because some people who question the
2020 election are now in positions of
prominence and Leadership we continue to
talk about and lie about the the 2020
election as if it was stolen as if it
Joe Biden wasn't the the real winner of
that election we keep lying about
January 6th and and the prisoners from
January 6th that the defendants um who
are not political prisoners but but
rather uh committed crimes they
assaulted police officers they uh
damaged government property and so I I
don't think we can have the credibility
we need with the American public if we
continue the lies uh that we're now
telling good grief man
they say that we won't get over this
stuff they say that we who are a little
skeptical of some of the rule changes in
20120 and they say that we won't get
over it we're living in the past talk
about the pot calling the kettle black
give it a rest man the election was
obviously rigged but even if you think
it was perfect even if you Ken Buck
believe it was the most perfect election
ever conducted and Joe Biden got 10
gazillion votes and he's the most
popular president ever in America
contrary to all evidence available to
that's the most important thing to you
as a member of Congress not immigration
not the outbreak of War not the economy
not helping struggling Americans not
this that or the other thing no no no
the most important thing is that every
single elected Republican hails the
great leader Joe Biden and says that he
was obviously totally elected without
any questions that's it that's the most
important thing to you what a joke no
wonder the GOP is is the considered the
junior partner in the liberal
establishment because so many people the
squishes their their role is to be the
Court Jester in the Kingdom of
liberalism and to push back just enough
that it seems like there's opposition
and then at the crucial moments to lay
down and roll over
pathetic there's much more to get to
we'll have to get to it tomorrow because
I'm going to Cornell today I'm going to
be up at Cornell if you are in Ithaca
New York I hear that Ithaca is
gorgeous gorgeous do you get if you're
around there come on up uh we will be
discussing you me in World War II
tonight at Cornell so I hope to see you
in itha I'm not sure if tickets are
still available but in any case just go
on
the yaf Young America Foundation website
or just Google Michael nlls Cornell it
should come up see if you can get a
ticket the rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it become a
member use code nolles KW a check out
for 2 months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
oh